varias conclusiones salen de esta
primera rueda de prensa del recién
electo presidente ibrahim rise y es un
nombre concreto empezó la rueda de
prensa en el momento que era no se
extendió mucho como son unas células
presidentes de irán y sus preguntas
fueron bastante concretas todos mensajes
tanto de la política interna como de la
política externa en alto la política
interna es un mensaje fue recuperar la
economía ayudar a la población más
necesitada y recuperar esa confianza de
la población en el sistema y en el
régimen que está debilitado como quedó
en evidencia en estas elecciones de la
participación fue de menos del 50 por
ciento en cuanto a política exterior
habló del acuerdo nuclear dijo que su
política exterior no giraría en torno a
este acuerdo pero que si eeuu volvía a
cumplir los compromisos irán volvería a
hacerlo siempre pensando en el beneficio
de la población dijo que los misiles y
la participación de irán en la región no
eran negociable y en cuanto a esas
ejecuciones masivas en la década de los
80 de las cuales él hizo parte dijo
defendían los derechos humanos y que
fueron los acusados de entonces quienes
rompieron esos derechos humanos cuando
se oponían a las reglas de la república
islámica